- [Narrator] Most people know helium
as the lighter than air gas
that fills our party balloons.
But more importantly it's
an irreplaceable element
for science and industry.
Helium was discovered in
1868 during a solar eclipse.
Astronomers observed a yellow
light in the sun's corona
and couldn't explain it
with any known elements
at the time.
Their observations turned
out to be the first sightings
of a new element and given
its discovery near the sun
this element was named after
the Greek god of the sun,
Helios.
Helium is the second lightest element.
Second only to hydrogen.
It's located near the
top of the periodic table
coming in at atomic number two.
Meaning it has two protons in its core.
It's usually found in gas form
but turns into liquid below
negative 452 degrees Fahrenheit.
Helium is the second most
abundant element in the universe.
Created during the Big Bang
and found in stars, planets,
and even our own moon.
However it's relatively rare on earth.
On our planet, helium forms
as a gaseous byproduct
of ancient uranium that's
decayed over billions of years
and is trapped beneath
the earth's surface.
It's harvested from natural gas reserves
and can't be artificially produced
making helium a non-renewable
resource on our planet.
Helium has a variety of applications
largely due to its unique characteristics.
It's a noble gas so it's
less likely to interact
with other elements.
When mixed with neon, helium
can create low power lasers
used to scan barcodes
at checkout counters.
When mixed with oxygen in
a high pressure environment
helium allows deep sea
divers to breath in the air
from their oxygen tanks more easily.
And since helium has a low boiling point,
it's useful in extremely
cold temperatures.
Because of this it can cool
some of the most powerful
electromagnets on earth
including the large Hadron Collider.
While helium can be applied
in seemingly countless ways,
its availability is finite.
Because it's lightweight
when helium is released
into the atmosphere it floats into space
and is lost to earth forever.
(drumline playing)
But by pursuing avenues
of helium recycling,
exploration, and storage,
we may be able to protect and sustain
this precious non-renewable resource.